manni ist als herr tutorial der
supergroup bei youtube schon wird er mit
fanpost überhäuft er ist im frühjahr
2009 gestartet hat er jetzt bereits rund
60.000 abonnenten damit ist er einer der
topstars bei youtube warum er erfolg hat
und andere nicht erklärt er in der
online talkshow clixoom de wird einfach
mal denken dass ich wie das für die
allgemeinheit macht sie so gestaltet
dass die unterhaltungswert haben tipps
und tricks beinhalten und einfach ich
selbst bin und daten das ist glaube ich
auch mein
geheimtipp an alle die erfolgreich
wehren wollen ihr nehmt euch muss so
sieht das dann aus dem gemahlenen
aufgebrühten kaffee dann fügt ihr ein
viertel von der gesamtmenge des cafés an
honig so dann habt ihr das und
geschmerzt euch einfach los am besten
nimmt auch die hand dazu sieht jetzt ein
bisschen es offene kleine dora aber
glaubt mir danach sollte eure haut
natürlich gefehlt seien dabei kniete auf
einem sitzkissen vor dem fenster und der
computer steht da wo er eigentlich nicht
hingehören im programm was ich einfach
anschlag das ist ein movie hd damit
nimmt er die videos auf und schneidet
sie aber nicht alle finden seine videos
gut es gibt eine menge hater die nicht
ganz so nette kommentare schreiben das
ist so ein zitat eines meiner lieblings
zitate härter sind wie sandpapier sie
können sich an der reiben sie können
sich an mir
zerkratzen aber am ende bin nicht der
aus geschliffener diamant und sie sind
abgeschnitten ist habt ja außerdem
trösten ihn die fans mit selbst
gemachten geschenken